let me try drawing the 45-45-90 triangle
here this angle measures 45 degrees and
so does this one we say it's special
because given any one side of this
triangle we can easily find the lengths
of the other two
it means given one side we can find the
lengths of all the sides we also know
that sides opposite equal angles are
equal so a B will be equal to BC and
as-90 is greater than 45 both these
sides will be smaller than AC in the
45-45-90 triangle the three sides are in
the ratio 1 is to 1 is 2 root 2 in
variable terms if a b is a then bc will
also be a and AC will be a root 2 let's
experiment with numbers what if a B is 3
if this length is 3 then this one as
well has to be 3 so BC will be 3 and
based on the ratio AC will be 3 root 2
this was easy
now what if AC is 4 if AC is 4 then a B
will equal 4 by root 2 multiplying a
with root 2 gives us a root 2
multiplying 4 by root 2 with root 2
gives us 4 and VC will also equal 4 by
root 2 and just like I asked you in the
30-60-90 video what should we do if we
forget this ratio if we forget the ratio
all we need is to draw the 45-45-90
triangle again as both these sides are
equal let's call them X and let's call
this one y as this is a right triangle
based on the Pythagoras theorem we can
say that x squared plus x squared is
equal to y squared so 2x squared will
equal Y squared transposing to to the
other side we get x squared as Y squared
by 2 and
taking the square root on both sides we
get X as Y by root 2 y will be X root 2
and that gives us the ratio as X is 2 X
is 2x root 2 or 1 is 2 1 is 2 root 2 so
we just applied the Pythagoras theorem
in this triangle and we have the ratio
we're looking for